l'étape de l'année on va s'intéresser au
top de l'année bien évidemment j'ai fait
un petit magret cap et on en parle juste
après
dans la catégorie ou et du top de
l'année les nommés sont
hpi pour ses audiences aussi élevé que
le cui doute des fleurot et c'est ce
qu'elle a mangé à midi
un geste est un tour qui loue des sushis
et un soda soit 300 calories à dix jours
de rentrer dans sa robe de mariée à
l'antenne ça passe à baba pour ses
records successifs sur la tnt etc entrée
digne du festival de cannes
[Musique]
mariée au premier regard pour ses
séquences toujours un peu olé olé 6%
militaire je comptais donné deux ans on
a vraiment fait la découverte de l'un
envers l'autre
s'est endormi l'un dans l'autre
et les 20 ans de la star academy pour
les plus nostalgiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant poser la question
[Musique]
et lloris aurait été plus d'un million
deux cent mille spectateurs ouais c'est
ça c'est dit après les autres c'est pas
mal mais bon il est vrai noté c'était sa
prochaine la russie a eu de l'impact
quoi et non vie sexuelle c'est une super
émission on va c'est maintenant aux cetc
huit d'or les flops de l'année et alors
je vous dirai arrêtez on avait
l'embarras du choix ce qu'on a vu un
nombre de boue cette année c'était le
cas c'est le record de m alors non
[Rires]
d'ailleurs si vous savez quoi vous et
moi on est un peu de base c'est les
bulles à la ramener à qui fait mal hein
tout genre à
regarder leur éclat
[Rires]
dans la catégorie the world du flop de
l'année les nommés sont un flirt et une
danse pour ces moments de gêne aussi
bien du côté du fleuve que de la danse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai passé un super bon moment mais j'ai
pas eu des papillons dans ma vente et si
j'ai pas de papillon ça veut dire je
risque pas de tomber amoureuse de toi
hôtel du temps pour ses effets spéciaux
à couper le souffle vidalies comestar
belle écoute beaucoup mieux la vie que
je suis à l'hôtel du temps fait vous
avez en commun d'avoir connu l'égide du
roi farouk et d'avoir quitté pour la
france tous les deux tant père était
français famille bourgeoise lyonnaise il
était chef du trafic sur le canal de
suez l'eurovision 2022 et on sait qu'ils
sont arrivés avant dernier du concours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et enfin des pépites xl pour son
émission de karaoke qui fait du bien aux
oreilles
[Musique]
jours
m
et voyez qu'on est alors qu'ils
emportent le syli d'or de la plus belle
job de l'année la réponse juste après la
pub nous étions dans les flops de
l'année je t'ai remarquer ali bernès
qu'on était bien d'ailleurs
mérité alors à votre avis où tous qui
mérite ce flop parmi les quatre cités on
avait on avait un flirt une danse butoh
hôtel du temps fréquence qui remet à
l'ambition révision 22 voilà et tp mpxl
très très mal payés indécent ardisson de
la
danse / va se passer est extrêmement
aller voir ces cellules gênant à ségécé
c'est très très très gênant c'est être
contre quelqu'un pour danser et il faut
que tu le sais tu pas payant et c'est
terrible c'est terrible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment tu t'appelles d'abord je
m'appelle sylvain silence à l'us carmaux
à céchi là c'était un super plaisir de
danser avec toi et j'ai passé un super
bon moment mais j'ai pas eu des
papillons dans ma vente et si j'ai pas
de papillon ça veut dire je risque pas
de tomber amoureuse de toi qu'est ce
qu'il est un numéro de téléphone
l'émission
c'est en coulisse voilà merci beaucoup
et dans les coulisses
[Applaudissements]
à l'ancien directeur des divertissements
de france 2 oui et ce qui passe dans la
tête d'une unité de divertissement pour
acheter un programme pareil on va se
séduire en dansant comme des pieds
ça m'a bien fait rire dans le ventre pas
vous répondre et je trouve même le
programme triste parce qu'il ya des
moments là par exemple ce qu'on vient de
voir je trouve ça un peu triste machine
à paris c'est mal au coeur je sais pas
quoi dire je ne sais pas ce qui s'est
passé c'est de la merde quoi oui on sait
le personnel et des
personnes avaient des convictions
qu'elle a mis ce programme on ne savait
peut-être marcher pour le public de
france 3 les danserien moi je peux pas
que ccb ccht relativement cher oui on
est à 600 700 mille euros le boucan
massivement même effacé un bruit bah oui
quand même alors pour défendre le
programme il ya quand même une séquence
qui était très belle c'est deux
personnes qui se connaissaient et en
fait c'était des zeks est ici bien
encore et donc à la dame quand elle
s'est retournée vers l'avant son ex
son ex au final ils ont dit on sème
encore et ça c'était beau c'était le
ciel passage qui était beau et puis
rennes pour ça c'est joli mais bon si
cent mille euros c'est quand même
chercher la rue ben moubamba le problème
c'est qu'on s'en fout totalement se fout
des gens qui dansent ensemble est ce que
ça va faire on se fout du jury on se
fout de l'enjeu on se fout de tours se
fout de l'émission
[Applaudissements]
danse avec les stars il avait fait un
effort de chorégraphies voronine nous
ont revisité time of my life là là le
mec il s'est retourné dans sa tombe en
panne alors hôtel du temps hôtel du
temps annoncé comme une révolution de
l'interview à grand renfort d'effets
spéciaux et telle heure
on est tellement cher tellement jamais
alors on va le revoir un petit extrait
avec claude françois mais pas on perd
son âme
salut dalil comestar belle écoute
beaucoup mieux depuis que je suis à
l'hôtel du temps en fait vous avez en
commun d'avoir connu l'égide du roi
farouk et d'avoir quitté pour la france
tous les deux tant père était français
famille bourgeoise lyonnaise il était
chef du trafic sur le canal de suez il y
est très bien sa vie on avait une grande
villa ismaila tu m'a raconté que ta mère
jouait du piano et cotait de fer avec un
musicien comme mon père oui un pianiste
l'autre violoniste d'ailleurs il a fallu
que j'apprenne le violon je détestais ça
ma soeur s'était le piano mais les
meilleurs moments c'était le soir quand
nous passions des heures assis sur le
trottoir devant le café noir
[Applaudissements]
pire alors cessé ardisson parce qu'il
s'est bien fait sans lui le chiffonnier
gms guinée ces milliards ont appris les
meilleurs infographiste personnes lra
graphiste dibindi lille les intrigues
[Rires]
bon alors l'appareil la promesse qu'elle
était la promesse objectivement aucune
promesse c'est à dire dieu il n'ya pas
de promesses c'est à dire quelle est la
raison c'est comme dans un restaurant il
faut que ça donne envie là en
l'occurrence que cela donne envie droits
leurs emails et mots sur parler des
morts non non et à faire parler les
morts je connais mon rêve de pouvoir
communiquer avec les morts la grippe
pour les nouilles avait pas d'émotions
dépasser pas une émission 17 23 pas de
lien pas d'émotions c'est juste de faire
parler les morts et fait des mois que
ses amis l'examen blizzard est ce que
vous n'en tirez rien ça nous donne pas
envie hein c'est un problème encore une
fois tristesse que quand patrick
sébastien avait fait
qu'il était grimé en magre en mer on
jure que j'avais eu peur sur la séquence
avec des fils de frédéric dard où il
s'était retrouvé face à lui et la cde
les motos sont donc souvent le pleurer
tandis que là en l'occurrence est ce que
vous avez envie tout d'un coup de
françois mitterrand qui vous disent que
s'ils étaient là aujourd'hui en 2022
qu'est ce qui me ferait pas je veux dire
on s'en fout quoi faire quand on s'en
fout oui c'est tellement froid que ça
devient le cube re serre que ces glaces
en mêmes repoussant ils sont moches et
n'ont rien à dire c'est mal filmé quel
est l'intérêt non mais quelle est la
vraie raison c'est finalement chez elle
et qu'elle est la personne imbéciles qui
a décidé de programmer ce à la
télévision à quelle est la personne et
puis ça vous pouvez pas dire ça non plus
parce que c'est au club de décompression
est pas dissipé une question j'ai posé
questions diverses un peu répondre
de 800 mille ans de délire mais ç'a dû
recourir ta colère en deux émissions on
a quand même mis deux trois marchands de
tabac que c'est clair mais ce qui est
triste de lyon c'est nous qui payons ce
truc c'est quand une équipe ayant dû
décoller c'est nous qu'on paye il y en a
une il y en a une qui est déjà en bois
qui sera avec jean gabin et la chaîne
aurait demandé à thierry ardisson d'en
faire une des mânes non avec coluche
alors si si la limite prenez des gars
qui sont encore un peu dans l'actualité
prenez johnny sonné j'ai pas parce que
tu sais pas johnny ouais vous vous qui
entoure ce match et passer tour à lui
c'est alors pourrait abuser on ne
pouvait pas nous ne pouvait pas ne pas
vous remonterez tp mpx xmtch karaoké où
on a testé pour nous alors nous nous on
a passé une bonne soirée les gens
apparemment beaucoup moins visiblement
mais souvenez vous je crois qu'il y
avait eu c'était l'actualité était
compliqué vu de la guerre en ukraine
c'est la faute de ta grand mère
soyons honnête oui il a frôlé le
chef-d'oeuvre et on est tombé en rade au
stade
regardez
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
je vous
je chante extrêmement bien j'étais la
seule mesure
alors on va donc pour mettre un de ces
vite
acquis